hi everyone it's a pleasure to be with
you today and I'm pleased to take you
through this deck about somatic gene
recombination in the brain and my name
is Gerald Chung i'm at sanford burnham
protists medical Discovery Institute in
La Jolla California where I'm a
professor and senior vice president for
neuroscience drug discovery what I'd
like to tell you about is some some
recent work looking at potentially new
mechanism both for fundamental brain
science as well as LC mers disease we're
located in La Jolla and here's a picture
of our Institute it's right next to the
Torrey Pines Golf Course for for those
of you that have predilection for
golfing a lovely place come and visit us
so I'll start with a very basic level of
understanding and that's what's present
in textbooks about DNA and here's
something that came from the National
Human Genome Research Institute and it
was a question and answer day and they
were asking people in the audience to
send in questions and this question came
in do all cells have the same DNA and
the answer that was given was yes of
course all the cells in a person's body
have the same DNA in the same genes and
this is the answer you'll get from most
textbooks these days and yet when it
comes to the brain it's absolutely clear
that this is not true and that's because
of the existence of genomic mosaicism so
a way to think about this is in the next
slide a picture of a yellow rectangle
and let's assume that that rectangle a
rectangle is composed of billions and
billions of cells that have identical
genomes and what that means is that all
of the organization all the exquisite
complexity that's present in our brains
must arise post genomically however
there's another possibility which is
that that complexity that organization
actually involve
changes at the level of individual cell
genomes and if one were to look at that
in another way you could actually have
functions or organization emerging from
these individual cells that are
different at the level of their DNA and
that new order could arise from that
kind of organization and that's what
drove a lot of the studies to begin to
look at the individual genomes within
the cells of our brains the first
evidence that something was distinct
came from looking at brain development
and that's shown in the next slide in
which we looked using what at the time
was quite modern but is is now an
established technique to look at the
chromosomal complement within individual
neurons or neural progenitor cells in
this case of the brain and this was
using a technique called spectral
karyotyping and what it does is it in
essence paints chromosomes different
colors and so what you can see there in
the center image is that this progenitor
cell has three chromosome twos a single
15 in a single 17 and that's arrayed in
the diagram at the bottom so it's
clearly aneuploid and it's aneuploid in
a quite complex way and one may ask why
wasn't this observed in the past and I
think part of the reason is shown on the
pictures on the left and right in black
and white that you really couldn't
easily see what that complement of
chromosomes was using classical types of
Dappy on the left orgy banding on the
right so this type of an approach led to
the view that indeed many many cells
within our brains would actually or
could actually very at the level of
chromosome differences so these are
aneuploidies or technically an you so
meas if they're occurring within cells
where you don't know where all the
chromosomes are and if one looks at
where the field has moved in the last
couple of decades or so that's shown
here in terms of forms of neural genomic
mosaicism so from that initial
observation and
then one of aneuploidies a number of
other observations have emerged that
indicate that it has meaning affecting
gene expression occurring the circuits
and a number of other phenomena have
subsequently emerged that indicate that
other forms of mosaicism also exist
including line 1 elements from rusty
gauges lab DNA content variation that
I'll have more to say about in just a
second
then the era of single cell sequencing
that is upon us from Chris Walsh's lab
that indicated there may be some of
these Elwin elements being emerging or
entering the genome although at levels
that are still under investigation but
single-cell sequencing has revealed copy
number of variations or CNB's that's
indicated in the black there from work
from both Rusty's lab in our own with
kun zhang at UCSD and then moving to
single nucleotide variations work from
the Walsh lab as well as Kristen Baldwin
at Scripps research indicate that
individual neurons can have quite an
array of single nucleotide variations
that can be identified
one possible sequelae of this is changes
in the transcriptome in single cell
transcriptome studies that we and Kwon
Sang have done indicate an enormous
level of diversity that's present
amongst neurons of the human brain
of course many investigators have shown
that in the mouse brain and that might
in part be due to this complexity within
the genome the last point to making this
slide is the mosaicism does change with
conditions and in particular we found
that in Alzheimer's disease it can
change quite dramatically and I'll spend
the latter portion of the top telling
you about that so one of the techniques
we've used to get a view of many many
different cells at one shot is simply to
look at their DNA content and the way to
do that is to take individual cells and
isolate their nuclei which allows you to
use a cell analyzer that that
fluorescence to look at DNA content
after you've stained the DNA with any
number of fluorescent dyes so that
that's illustrated in a very simple way
in the left and on the right if you look
at the writing their DNA content
analysis the way these experiments are
done is you put in your experimental
sample that's the big peak and then you
spike in a positive control which are
chicken erythrocyte nuclei and then you
can line up samples from different
sources so using this technique we were
able to assess changes within the brain
and I should add that this general
technique is now widely used to look at
everything from the genome to
transcriptome in cells of the brain so
here we have an example of some of the
data that emerged to reveal DNA content
variation and if you look on the far
right there are three samples in blue
green red and they've been overlaid and
so in each of a B and C you can see
chicken or other site nuclei form a
single peak and these are all three
experiments overlaid on each other and
they are basically the same however if
you look at the samples from the
cerebellum there's a little bit at the
base along the x axis x axis a little
bit of spread there and that what that
indicates is some variation that's
present along the x axis and indication
of some DNA content changes and that's
even more dramatically seen in cells
from what's label as frontal cortex
where we have that right shoulder
and if we move to D you can see that
that right shoulder is colored in
magenta that that's a significant change
in the distribution of these cells and
it's occurring amongst cells of the
frontal cortex these cells can be seen
in an a [ __ ] a little view to the
right and E and that's a scatter that's
to the right of the image and sales for
the frontal cortex and we now know that
almost all of that extra DNA that's
present there is within the neuronal
component or a compartment although some
of the non neural cells may also
consider
the amounts that are gained are not
subtle it's some 250 million base-pairs
or 250 megabases
another way to look at this is to take
your samples from that DNA histogram as
shown in the gray picture and a and then
isolate them and then whole genome
amplify them and simply ask about how
much amplification one sees from your
fraction and if you do that for say a
hundred nuclei 500 nuclei or a thousand
nuclei you get changes as shown in B
where the low portion always is less
than the high portion not surprising but
independent validation for these
relationships and this is work done by
two great graduate students Diane
Bushman and Gwen Kaiser as well as been
sitting a postdoc in the lab so this
brings us to Alzheimer's disease is the
most common cause of dementia a huge
societal and economic costs some two
hundred seventy seven billion dollars
per year in the u.s. we still do not
understand the most common forms of the
disease that constitute about ninety
five ninety nine percent of cases and
they're called sporadic because we don't
understand what is causing them there
are no disease modifying therapies
excuse me
despite hundreds of failed clinical
trials and about only one percent by
important important one percent are
linked to rare genes and families and
these are so-called familial Alzheimer's
disease cases and one gene particular is
amyloid precursor protein or a P P this
gene is pathogenic if it's mutated or
present in three copies as occurs in
Down syndrome or basically everyone gets
Alzheimer's disease by the time they're
about forty or the neuro pathology of
Alzheimer's disease or rare familial
forms of a P P duplication that also has
three copies all of those folks get
Alzheimer's as well so a B P gains in
copy number are extremely important in
familial and in Down syndrome
Alzheimer's it's important that one has
difficulty or in might in some cases
basically be impossible
to detect these kinds of changes
occurring within the brain if you're
using standard ways of looking for human
disease genes and these are of course G
loss types of studies genome-wide
Association studies because you take
cells from the periphery and you isolate
their DNA and then you sequence them and
why it's you're not actually
interrogating cells from the brain
itself and if you have these large
changes let's say 250 million base pairs
in a given cell you won't be able to see
them using these peripheral sources of
DNA so what does one see in the sporadic
cases and if you take cells from the
prefrontal cortex as we did but now
we're looking at Alzheimer's disease we
see even more increased DNA content
variation so what's shown in this slide
are most likely increased dcv in
Alzheimer's disease neurons and the gain
is about 450 million base pairs of a
reference or another 200 million base
pairs over a non disease case and once
again you're looking at three different
situations the lymphocytes versus to
Alzheimer's disease cases in red and
blue and if you look at the d4 the
cortical samples you can see that there
is an increase in the DNA content within
those populations that's not seen within
the cerebellum from the same individual
so this is something that is shows
regional variability as well and once
again we have about a 450 billion base
pair increase over reference genomes so
what might this mean for Alzheimer's
disease well one is to ask the general
question of how pervasive is this and
basically if one looks at a population
as shown here in F you can see that
there is a statistically significant
increase as one goes from person to
person each of those little diamonds is
an individual brain and cells from the
cortex of those brains have more DNA on
average you can see or the means that
are indicated by the red bars as
compared to the other conditions that
don't show the same increase
in G H and I are different ways of
looking at the distributions of these
cells whereby again in the cortex one
sees more DNA and there's more
variability and I an indication that
there's more going on within these
populations so if one asks the question
of what this might do to Alzheimer's
disease a clear possibility is it might
affect that a PP gene because it as I
mentioned earlier increases in both Down
syndrome the three copies or those
families that have three copies in all
of whom will get Alzheimer's disease I
should add right off the bat there was
no evidence for increased trisomy 21 in
sporadic Alzheimer's disease there is
trisomy 21 interestingly enough but it
is not increased over non disease
controls so we looked at this in a
couple of different ways in one way we
looked at it using a fluorescence based
technique that did not require
polymerase amplification and in the
other we looked at it using a
single-cell quantitative PCR so let's
take a look at the fluorescence first
and this is the way we approached it by
using what are known as peptide nucleic
acid probes and you these are used for
telomere studies we stick on a single
Fleur onto these probes which can be
hybridized against a given target and we
targeted a three prime and a five prime
exons so the five prime x on here is in
the purple star that's exon 3 and the 3
prime is the exon 14 and then we
visualize them using structured
illumination microscopy and then we also
tossed in a positive control which was a
telomere which shows up in red so you
gonna see red and you're gonna see green
and that's shown here in the next slide
let's start on the far right you can see
a cell from a normal brain with all the
red signals there and one does not see
the endogenous low sy with this approach
because we've threshold it it's we don't
see them however in the cell below it
you can see in green dot and that green
dot is an indication of the locus it has
more than
two copies and in fact probably has
several copies of a PP is this indeed a
good representation of what's going on
and if one looks at the quantitative PCR
signals coming from these samples this
time not using brains for using
individual cells as shown in a you can
see that out there on the far right of
that where there's a star there's
Alzheimer's disease cortex that all of
those little cells indicated by diamonds
show increased copy number above what we
would see under these other non disease
conditions or cerebellar conditions so
that's an indication as that there are
more copies and in some cases as many as
12 copies were observed by qPCR and
right next to it is that the histogram
of fluorescence output that also shows
similar shape so two independent
techniques support this view but there
were a couple of interesting oddities if
you will one was the morphology of these
signals as shown in this slide
where you can see that the green dot
let's start at the very top going from
left to right the little circle there
indicates that there is more copies but
if you're simply adding more coffees to
the circle you might expect it to stay a
circle but that's not always observed
some copies like in the second three
we're kind of blobby and at the very
bottom really blobby so there's some
real inhomogeneities in the signal in
fact it looks as though some portions of
it have increased signal over the other
as shown in the far right that's showing
the the heat map with red being more
more signal moreover if once again we
looked at qpcr to look at the
relationship between the exons we saw
something that was actually quite
supportive and that was discordant exon
pairs so here we're looking at
quantitative PCR and each of the cells
at the bottom 1 through 23 are single
cells and we've looked at both exons in
those single cells and what you can see
is that there's general concordance
however there are lots of examples where
it's not concordant
and those are the purple and green stars
were Exxon 3 or 14 maybe over or under
represented and it was that difference
that really suggested that something
else was going on besides there's been
simple hole amplification of the gene
and that led us to look quite closely at
what was going on and resulted in this
paper somatic a ppg and recombination in
else high murmurs disease and normal
neurons and it was driven by Ming Shan
Li a great postdoc in the lab and then a
whole really excellent team of
researchers who are shown here Ben Billy
Christine Chris when Eagle or tau rich
and grace and I'll be showing you work
next that that the team was able to
pursue now part of having a team is that
one can have people do things over and
over again to make sure that we're not
making mistakes and in fact as shown
here in the next slide this table which
is from the paper indicates nine
distinct approaches that were
reproducibly carried out in the lab that
support what I'm about to tell you and
actually if you take those nine and you
add it to the three other techniques
from the work that I just mentioned
looking at the increase in fluorescence
and qPCR that's some 12 independent or
distinct approaches that support the
existence of somatic gene recombination
just underscore that there is
reproducibility for these data one may
ask right off the bat why don't we just
go ahead and sequence these single
neurons it seems like that technology
exists but in fact it does not exist and
it's shown here and the problem is that
the coverage is very very low for this
type of sequencing experiment so for
example in Rusty's 2013 paper the
coverage there was 0.01 3 X and today
even the best coverage is only about 0.1
X for a single cell and similarly the
resolution generally somewhere in the
ballpark of a number of mega bases
even the best current resolution is
still only about half a mega base and
why does that matter it's because the a
PP locus itself is only 0.3 mega bases
three hundred kilobases and it probably
requires something on the ballpark about
four hundred X coverage to see something
and thus it's just not possible to
identify the sorts of changes one might
want to see using the standard types of
sequencing technologies so to get at it
we approached it in a couple of
different ways we looked at both RNA and
DNA but remember this is a mosaic
situation and so rather than looking at
a whole bucket of cells we just looked
at a few at a time in order to capture
the diversity that might be present so
here's a general approach first with RNA
and in other pictures you'll see a DNA
just to distinguish what we're looking
at so here in the first set of figures a
we're looking at the brain taking the
neurons taking their nuclei and then
carrying out reverse transcriptase PCR
to look at their RNAs and in the gel
that's illustrated to the right and B
what you see are a bunch of bands that
have little arrows on them and there are
other bands as well those are bands that
are not supposed to be there they're
smaller than the predicted forms of the
RNAs for a P P and those are illustrated
the expected types of bands are
illustrated in D E and F so DS Genoa
cloak Asst which then gets spliced to
form a full-length oh so called seven
seven zero variant that turns out not to
be expressed in brain because the brain
has brain specific forms that's shown in
F and there's a 751 and a 695 that lack
certain exons turns out XM 8 exon 7 and
8 respectively those are what we
expected to see but all these little
bands what what are they so in C we did
an old-fashioned southern blot with an
internal probe to the primers and it lit
up so that said hey maybe it's something
interesting we cloned them by by
standard methodologies and Sanger
sequenced them and what we found or a
whole bunch of little truncated form
and those are illustrated here and the
nomenclature is the RNA for the R and
then the X on one say slash 11 on the
far right and then they're just
different numbers of varieties that
we've solved that particular form and
these are truncated APB farms that
characterized by having these cDNA like
portions and in addition they have these
intra exonic junctions that are joined
via homology regions from one exon to
the next within the exon so it's not the
exon exon of a splice Junction but
rather something that occurs within the
exon itself so all of these forms have
not been previously reported but of
course there's that horrible possibility
that maybe this is some PCR artifact so
to get around that we looked at a
completely different bit of information
this is from a library made commercially
by Pacific Biosciences using single
molecular realtime sequencing that's an
important new technology relatively new
technology that allows one to look at
single molecule sequence rather than
requiring comparison to a reference and
what this showed is that the same types
of intra conic junctions and truncations
were present in the messages of a
completely independently derived library
arguing against any kind of an artifact
so where is this coming from and as you
might imagine our bias was that it was
coming from the genome itself so we
began to look at that let me add that
I'll be showing you some pictures with
varieties that show the 316 on the far
right or 1617 these are some of the
species that we sequenced and we made
specific probes against them so here we
are now in DNA and if you we did exactly
the same thing taking a few cells and
piece yard but this time no reverse
transcriptase so we're looking at
genomic DNA and there's a gel there on
the right and once again you see small
bands these small bands are not supposed
to be there but they were consistent
with the RNA
note that there's one group there it
says s ad three and there's some smears
in there I'm gonna come back to those
smears in just a second in addition we
carried out DNA in situ hybridization
using probes that allow you to see
actual genes but using Institue
hybridization very very importantly we
could do this using the sense strand not
the anti sense as one uses for RNA in
situ hybridization and so this allowed
us to help differentiate it from RNA
lastly we did a pulldown as shown in
number four of that section which allows
you a completely independent method to
try to identify things that look like
genomic cDNAs so here's an example of
the DNA in situ hybridization or dish so
the sense in anti sense in e h e and h
are two different forms from the the
sixteen seventeen and three sixteen
targets and you see pretty much the same
signal as you would expect and
especially the sense strand is showing
it an indication that it's not RNA it's
in the DNA and that's supported in km
where we restriction endonuclease
destroyed the target sequence we also
had positive controls with using
retroviruses with synthetic targets that
also indicated specificity so we're
looking at a DNA signal here and what
you can see is that they're in fact
quite a few signals in some cases and
that's illustrated in onp where you can
see the endogenous this case where we
are revealing the endogenous signal with
two alleles in the magenta
Errol's and then the greenish bluish
arrows they show as for example an Oh a
bunch of signals an indication that
we're seen with a sense Tran in DNA
targets that are identified and in some
cases they're quite a few of them within
single cells finally looking at the
pulldown we see sequencing reads that
are present on all of the x tonic
borders that are normally a
characteristic of AC
DNA note that in this array we see that
we're missing exon 8 why is that it's an
indication we believe that there's a
requirement for an RNA intermediate and
that it then gets copied to produce the
cDNA and we refer to these within the
genome as genomic cDNA x' or gen c DNA's
so what about that smear gram that I
show you in just now and that's
illustrated here where we see the
smearing that's an indication that there
may be quite a bit of diversity so we
use a different technique to look at
this and that is some of the same smart
sequencing that I had mentioned and if
one looks at what came out of that
analysis we get what's shown in the next
slide and so the general approach is
once again to take a few nuclei to PCR
and - we actually used a nested PCR we
got products in three and then we could
put on our adapters and then sequence
and what this approach allows you to do
is to sequence the same template over
and over and over again and as a result
you can get very high certainty
sequencing score is something on the
order of 99.999999 certainty and that's
comparable to Sanger sequencing and that
allows you to see things that you might
not be able to see with just a few
passes of the polymerase and here's what
we saw looking at e on the right is a
circle plot and on the very outer most
rim are the exons 1 through 18 and what
you see immediately going into the
center or the intra exonic junctions
that are present and then the dots that
are present in a log score in the
concentric circles that are an
indication of deletions insertions and
single nucleotide variations and so
non-diseased brains do give you signal
but Alzheimer's disease brains give you
a lot more signal and that's shown on
the far left where we see lots and lots
of dots and those are of many different
forms and let me call your attention to
the a beta region that red streak and
then look
the dots near that a beta region you can
see some with red around them what are
those in the next slide we can see what
they are they are in fact pathogenic
mutations are the same as what are seen
in familial disease but now they're
occurring in sporadic Alzheimer's
disease and they're absent from disease
controls so these are single nucleotide
variations that are identical to the
familial forms but they're occurring in
these pathogenic occurring and sporadic
Alzheimer's disease the last thing to
note here is that in fact there are many
changes that are occurring within this
population particularly if one goes from
H we can see that there's a number of
different forms the black and the gray
are in fact what one normally sees with
splice variants except they're in
genomic DNA as compared excuse me to f1
we see there's a vast change in a loss
of those black and gray and a
replacement by other colors indication
that there's a big shift in the
different types of forms as one looks at
the relationship to Alzheimer's disease
further we can see that there's a marked
increase in the else high risk disease
neuron signals as shown in a and
quantified in B and also in D and E such
that we see a signal in neurons but not
the non neuronal populations and they're
markedly increased in Alzheimer's
disease this is also supported by an
animal model in which which has been
well studied called the j-20 miles in
two shows some of the same variants even
though it was not produced with these
variant forms that's shown in G and the
endogenous signal actually increases
with time as shown in I and J and it
only does so within the neuronal
compartment and this is a trans gene
driven by a neuron specific promoter and
indication that transcription is in fact
required for this process and that it
changes over
just as Alzheimer's disease requires
time to manifest lastly if one looks at
the production of these genomic cdnas
one can see that it requires at least
three different components one that I'd
mentioned earlier is gene transcription
the second is that DNA strand breakage
is required and the third reverse
transcriptase activity is required I
won't take you through all of the
details here but what I can say is that
one can produce in cell lines these
genomic cDNAs although interestingly
they're sequence is a little bit
different than what's seen in the brain
perhaps an indication that there are
other factors that are also involved and
that shown in see by in addition if one
looks at H in this picture you can see
we're looking at reverse transcriptase
activity and it does exist in the brain
that's important and that it's an
indication that there's some endogenous
source of reverse transcriptase activity
that is yet to be determined there are a
good number of different aspects of
genomics II DNA's that are noted here
and in the interest of time I won't
belabor it other than to say that there
are indeed a number of elements novel
elements that characterize these most
prominently they are the genomic cDNAs
and they require this combination of
gene transcription strand breakage and
reverse transcription so one might ask
why does this matter well one thing is
that the brain really is a genomic
mosaic and it's at a mosaic at multiple
levels with multiple different types of
analyses the most recent of which is
somatic gene recombination secondly one
can look at this from the standpoint of
molecular biology and of course we all
know that DNA goes to RNA goes to
protein from Watson and Crick but we
also know that for viruses as shown here
that it can get reversed so-called
reversal the central dogma going from
RNA to DNA and that's of course through
reverse offense
and that is a critical part of the
retroviral lifecycle and most
prominently for the retrovirus HIV but
now we can add you know exceeding A's to
this certainly for a P P and we believe
for other genes as well so this is a
phenomenon that does that reverse
process involving normal and modified
cellular genes in normal neurons this
appears to occur through this process
going from double-stranded DNA s to your
pre Arman RNA that's spliced and copied
and then goes into the genome to form
the genomic cDNA and this might be
important for taking activity dependent
recording of a gene
perhaps one that's preferred or modified
and allows you to strengthen connections
by selecting for a given unsliced or
previously spliced version of the gene
that gives you a particular selective
capabilities and it may be something
underline what's known as a heavy n' as
heavy and plasticity or heavy and
synapse neurons that fire together wire
together perhaps this contributes to
that process what about in Alzheimer's
disease well the same types of things
can be going on but we believe they they
go wild they go awry and if you look at
the bottom of this process you can see
that might hit specific genes or other
genes could generate thousands of new
genes which might explain clinical trial
failures that look at only one molecular
species or could have adverse effects
because of insertion like some mobile
elements do but in addition if the cycle
is iterative and it goes round and round
and round then one would also have the
problem of creating the or encountering
the sloppiness of the reverse
transcriptase that produces more single
nucleotide variations which is exactly
what we observe some of which appeared
to be pathogenic in their similarity to
familial disease and that raises a
really interesting possibility because
there is a disease that's been treated
with reverse transcriptase inhibitors
HIV through their combination
antiretroviral therapies that include
these
verse transcriptase inhibitors so we can
ask a couple of questions that one is
what's the prevalence of Alzheimer's
disease in general well it's about one
in 10 people aged 65 years and older and
if you look at the number of people that
have HIV and are of this age there are
about a hundred twenty thousand of them
now so that would predict there'd be
anywhere from say on who were average
ten percent twelve thousand if it's just
three percent thirty six hundred
seventeen percent twenty thousand four
hundred but anyway thousands of cases
and so how many cases have appeared in
peer-reviewed literature and in fact in
2016 the first case so one case has
appeared thus far and that was based on
a positive amyloid PET scan so that
raises the possibility that perhaps
there is some type of relationship that
can be accessed
now using fda-approved reverse
transcriptase inhibitors and in fact
sort of independent analyses of insurer
databases is showing up similar types of
trends so we feel quite excited and
optimistic that this may in fact be be
reachable in terms of what might be used
for patients and that's the last slide
is to iterate that that there are no
approved disease modifying therapies for
Alzheimer's disease and these reverse
transcriptase inhibitors are
fda-approved for both HIV and hepatitis
B and so it's possible that they could
be utilized and in the u.s. there are
options already on the books for non
approved agents however we're talking
about approved agents that could be
prescribed off-label it's important to
note that all of the different agents
that are currently under investigation
will not have the years of post approval
safety that these agents have until long
after the current crop of Alzheimer's
disease patients is gone so there is the
possibility that these agents could be
used today this leaves this final slide
showing the different
forms of mosaicism of course the the
CNB's the SMB is the aneuploidies and
now we can add a gene recombination to
that set exactly which for max when is
still an important thing to determine
but it raises the possibility that
there's a lot more that can be
understood both in the normal and
diseased brain and it suggests that
there may be new therapeutics on the
horizon for treating genes that are
affected by somatic gene combination
including fda-approved reverse
transcriptase inhibitors that I thank
you all for your attention and want to
recognize many of the folks that have
done this work as well as support from
the Schaffer and Bundy foundations and
the NIH thank you very much for your
time and I'm happy to take questions by
email so please send them my way and
once again thanks for your time